ornella modérant bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
le disait les forces françaises avec
l'opération marcade très offensive 1 ces
derniers jours contre les terroristes
ont mali est ce qu'il ya une crainte
finalement que les groupes terroristes
se replie au burkina faso alors je pense
que la porosité des frontières est une
réalité au mali au burkina faso et au
niger les goûts les groupes qu'on a une
certaine facilité à passer les
frontières et on peut toujours se poser
la question de savoir surtout dans un
contexte où les groupes sont sous
pression
du côté malien non seulement à cause des
différences frappé attaque mais aussi à
cause de la proche de dialogue qui est
en train d'être envisagée ou tester est
ce qu'au final il n'aurait pas un effet
de vases communicants avec sa poupe qui
effectivement au descendrait d'une
alibert le nom du burkina
alors on parlait de ces attaques de
cette attaque au burkina faso pour
autant la force barkallah ce qu'elle est
un espoir encore aujourd'hui pour une
stabilisation de la région
alors le mandat de la force par cannes
et quand même si de l'ain territoire qui
est extrêmement extrêmement large
il est difficile pour eux d'être partout
je pense que l'incident que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure l'assassinât de
ces 14 personnes doit être remis en
perspective dans un contexte sécuritaire
qui est extrêmement tendue dans dans la
moitié dans du burkina faso on a assisté
il ya quelques jours également le 10
novembre à l'assassinât du chauffeur de
l'un des candidats à la législative
clairement on est dans un contexte où
les forces en présence semble un peu
dépassé par l'ampleur de la menace
alors dans ce contexte quelles sont les
attentes un des burkinabè à quelques
jours du scrutin présidentiel prévu le
2 novembre exactement on est un homme
jour du scrutin présidentiel il est
question de la mise en place d'un plan
de sécurisation de de ce processus
électoral c'est un plan qui est tenu en
grande partie au secret donc les
autorités axe assure que son existence
mais les détails pour des raisons
évidentes ne sont pas connues malgré ça
on continue à assister à plusieurs
incidents graves et donc on est
réellement en droit de se poser la
question de savoir s'ils allaient voter
ne va pas vous présenter un artiste je
pense qu'il faut rajouter également que
d'après les dernières déclarations des
autorités électorales
une partie du territoire équivalent ont
plus ou moins à 18 % du territoire
national va être purement et simplement
exclus du processus puisque les
opérations de boeck ne pourront pas s'y
tenir
en raison de l'insécurité alors en
campagne le président roch marc
christian kaboré donc vise à un second
mandat de cinq ans et il a promis de
ramener la paix ses détracteurs lui
reprochent justement son incapacité à
lutter contre le terrorisme lors de son
premier mandat
les forces de défense du pays s est ce
qu'elles sont en mesure est ce qu'elles
sont capables de lutter efficacement
contre les djihadistes aujourd'hui bon
je pense que les cinq dernières années
ont été un véritable défi ferment les
portes burkinabè ont mobilisé et dans
mes moments d'énergie et énormément
également de ressources humaines et de
ressources financières pour faire face
mais elles continuent à faire face à une
une multiplication en fait des acteurs
armés
on est au burkina faso dans un contexte
de très forte fragmentation de cette
confiture alité avec des acteurs qui
sont extrêmement localisé qui sont très
mobiles qui sont difficiles à identifier
et donc au delà de ce qui est à la tête
de l'état ou pas on se pose vraiment la
question de s que les les les moyens de
combat dont on dispose et qui sont des
moyens de l'ordre de
la guerre conventionnelle correspond
vraiment à ce contexte je pense qu'il
sera très difficile d'arriver à une
stabilisation réelle tant qu'on n'est
pas dans une logique véritablement dans
une pratique de réponse coordonnée entre
les différents états et de réponses
qu'il va également un niveau très local
comment est-ce que la force barkered est
perçu aujourd'hui dans la région bon ça
je pense que c'est une question très
franco française il faut également
remettre l'intervention de la force par
câble dans un contexte sécuritaire été
marqué par ce que certains mails
qualifiés d'embouteillage puisqu'on a
les acteurs de de la mission onusienne
oumhani qui sont là la minus main on à
la france par canon à la force baqouba
qui est en train d'être mises en place
avec les acteurs pour rien et on a
évidemment des différentes armées
nationales du mahdi de venise est fait
pour qu'il a acquis s'investissent dans
cette dans cette lutte là globalement
chacun fait pas ça des on va dire une
une perception qui fait spécifique il
est souvent reproché à part cannes par
exemple d'être orienté très très
fortement sur david contre le terrorisme
uniquement et donne pas suffisamment
pour prendre en compte des questions
liées à la protection des civils
je pense que c'est c'est voilà c'est
peut-être lui les limites du mandat qui
affecte la perception que les
populations locales peuvent avoir de cet
or cela merci beaucoup on est là
modérant pour votre éclairage rappelle
que vous êtes chef de programme celle à
l'institut d'études de sécurité